were you surprised that it was shared of
like any other woman absolutely
I put the post right after I donated the
blood I got in my car I'm like I need my
friends to be out here
I need more people our community from
the Muslim community to come
underneath a chair and after what I
can't witness was my eyes what other
people are doing there
this is really the true American dream
the true American dream was nothing
about the land of opportunity the term
agreement is about the people around us
so we'd see all these lights and all
these shares they again another prove
that we live in the greatest nation on
earth
they great people to come to people who
look at the attacker
see that Islam
I seek to them word if you're watching
the TV on Friday when the whole world
was watching the funeral medalie that
was Islam that was the truest